but so again only eight percent of women
below the poverty line so the majority
do you not think facts matter well no
problems
that's becoming illegal now think of all
the things that are going to happen in
America
it's just gonna it's gonna be terrible
why is that your your thought that
everything like what's gonna happen
it was unlegalized in the first place
like because it wasn't happening it was
it wasn't unlegalized you might not know
how the US government works but it's not
illegal in the U.S it's not
so the way it works in the U.S is it's
state by state so you elect officials to
represent you in each state and that way
if if you're a pro-life person you can
move to a state that's pro-life if
you're pro-choice you can move to a
state that's pro-choice
well that's how the US government works
is you you have different laws in every
state